finally getting the long-awaited highly
anticipated trem life 4. ladies and
gentlemen Ray schremmurd sure life man
what up what up what up for Life simple
on the way April 7th the last time we
got I want to was it the last time we
got the double disc it was like the
double album was that three trim three
triple disc it was a Slim Jimmy size
swaley side and then the group yeah yeah
uh why now for for swim life four what
what made what made the timing right to
to give the fans what they've been
asking for man
it's just time
you know what I'm saying it's like so
much time already went by it's like
time you doing I'm passing by you know
I'm saying we got a complete now too
everything's just a line like
business-wise family-wise everything
everybody on the same page he on our
side even with the label everything's
just everybody on the same page it's
like the fans they waited more than long
enough and we appreciate everybody
waiting just sticking by us you know I'm
saying it's just time to put it out you
know say we gotta keep the Legacy going
like it was only the beginning anyway
stream like one two three it's still the
beginning phases you know I'm saying
it's still so much more to the stream
life than we ain't even show the world
you know I'm saying got the chance to
show the world so
it's a perfect timing it's crazy to see
you guys become like oh geez Man legends
in this [__] you know what I'm saying
like yeah the Journey's been so crazy
you guys have had so many uh Peaks and
valleys and we've kind of seen you guys
grow up in front of us like is this the
best music that we're getting from you
guys together so far
I ain't gonna say it's the best because
I feel like the fans judged that but
it's the same approach right we ain't
switching our approach like everything
we did
is got a good response from the people
we ain't switching our approach we just
continuing where we left off so it's
like they know we do they know what type
songs we make they know our cadences a
lot of our Melodies of course we showing
some new sides of us but man it's just
like it's great music it's sticking to
our code sticking to the racial
reformula I like the new album I feel
like it's a lot of growth being sold on
the album our content is a little
different the way that we approaching
the music is a little different you know
what I'm saying and like with all our
albums I feel like they had the people
had to learned like we had to grow on
them you know what I'm saying because we
always come different you guys gotta
evolve yeah yeah we always evolve and so
I really like this music you know what
I'm saying I like this album I feel like
it's a great entry into the shrimp life
four I mean just to the shrimp life you
know what I'm saying same chain okay so
I know you got you got into a bit of a
spat with my boy Millie's over the stand
sample online because he did a stand
sample it wasn't really a uh no it was
it was nothing like serious it was very
Innocent but yo you guys got the [__]
stand record on this album yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah we put it on there we
just got the clearance man shout out to
everybody
it's not just one person you know it's
not just Dino or it's ditto honestly
[__] it I think it is
you know what I'm saying but yeah it was
like a process going through the
clearing but you know I'm saying like we
just recently got the clearance and
perfect it's perfect time for the album
like so what kind of record is it are
you like redoing this the the melody or
is it like I'm like is that they doing
some turnip [__] like what kind of
record is it yeah it's like some turn up
and it's like that song I feel like the
world formed that song because
it was like some viral stuff going on
when I sung and this might put on a beat
and then the world just been playing
that yeah they want that version with
the beat so it's like
the world really produced that song you
feel me so the fan the fans produced it
yeah the fans produced that song so it's
it's just like they wanted it you know
saying we did it just like they wanted
we did a verse Jimmy Jimmy did a verse
we actually had
some some people are interested in
getting on it and it was I think it'd be
a good match but we're gonna see how it
goes but but it got to be done by April
7th so about eight weeks away literally
so every player is gonna play out but we
definitely got that song on there and
yes it's a lot of excitement around that
song so are y'all even being in
Mississippi growing up listening to
Eminem yeah yeah yeah for sure for sure
really no that was definitely my
favorite like it's not like a thing
where I used to like
go on and like I play That Eminem it's
just like our parents that was playing
like VH1 was playing it you know saying
we watched TV the media Atlas we had at
the time
for myself you were rapping was crazy I
used to like the way he wrote I used to
try to rap like him at one point in time
in my life you know what I'm saying
where are those songs now oh no no
because we got to hear those I was young
I don't even know how young I was but I
definitely was man I'm super Eminem fan
especially we had the video where it was
like 100 of him oh yeah it's real Slim
Shady he was real controversial yeah he
was tight yeah he was like all over MTV
too at the time it's like you couldn't
watch MTV and not see Eminem on TRL yeah
yeah and all that